veamos como luce el estado de cuenta de
flujo de efectivo del ejemplo
simplificado de mi compañía de envíos
cómo se vería ese estado de cuenta y
digo que es simplificado porque este es
un estado de cuenta de ingresos muy
sencillos para cada uno de estos
periodos en realidad no estoy mostrando
todos los gastos y todos los detalles
que se deben de tener en un estado de
cuenta real digamos que al inicio de
este año fiscal cuando comencé esta
compañía tenía 60 mil dólares sabemos
que en este ejemplo usamos 60 mil
dólares para comprar un camión nuevecito
y en el estado de cuenta del efectivo se
expresan estos gastos como inversiones
en bienes de capital que son propiedades
equipos y demás cosas similares
así que ponemos esos 60 mil dólares aquí
en inversiones en bienes de capital y
con suerte ustedes comprenderán mejor
esto recuerden que el estado de cuenta
de flujo de efectivo es una forma de
reconciliar las ganancias con el
efectivo inicial y con el efectivo final
analicemos esto nuestra ganancia aquí
este número que tenemos acá nuestra
ganancia en el primer periodo es de 30
mil dólares asumiendo que nada raro está
ocurriendo que puedan estar cambiando
este valor durante
a continuación tenemos la depreciación y
veamos qué es lo que hace la
depreciación con el estado de cuenta de
flujos de efectivo escribamos los
números primero aquí tenemos el valor de
depreciación ésta es la depreciación del
camión no el valor del camión es el
costo de ese camión distribuido durante
su vida útil así que se reparten 20 mil
durante los tres años de vida por lo que
en cada uno de estos periodos la
depreciación será de 20 lo que les
quiero mostrar aquí es calcular el
efectivo de las operaciones a partir de
qué tanto efectivo están produciendo las
operaciones y queremos agregar esta
depreciación a las ganancias por lo que
el efectivo de las operaciones serán 50
dólares y podría no parecer obvio para
ustedes pero piénsenlo
estos 20 mil dólares que estamos
mostrando como un gasto en cada periodo
que sería más obvio si viéramos el
periodo 2 en el período 3 lo estamos
mostrando como un gasto pero realmente
estos 20.000 no están saliendo del
negocio no se están yendo del negocio
estamos mostrando algo del gasto de años
antes
por lo que nada de efectivo ha salido
fuera de nuestro negocio por lo que
estos elementos de depreciación se deben
agregar a nuestra ganancia de
operaciones y ustedes me pueden decir
oye gastamos 60 mil dólares en especial
en el primer año pero estaba en
inversiones en bienes de capital ya que
este efectivo no se fue del negocio es
una inversión que hicimos y todo esto
funciona porque como vemos tenemos 50
dólares en efectivo de operaciones lo
que tiene sentido ya que nuestros
ingresos fueron 100.000 el costo de mano
de obra fueron 50 mil el salario de las
personas fue de 50 mil lo que nos deja
50 mil de ganancias y esto no fue un
gasto de efectivo así pues de nuestras
operaciones tenemos 50 mil dólares y
aquí tenemos las inversiones en bienes
de capital 60 mil dólares por el camión
por lo que en nuestro efectivo final es
60 más 50 menos 60 es nuestro efectivo
final será de 50 mil dólares y quizá se
vea más evidente si analizamos el
siguiente período nuestro efectivo de
inicio aquí es de 50 mil dólares el
mismo con el que terminamos el período
anterior nuestras ganancias de nuevo son
de 30 mil dólares
la ganancia más la de precisión tenemos
50 mil dólares de ganancia de operación
es igual que el año anterior o debería
decir del efectivo de las operaciones lo
que tiene sentido porque nuestras
operaciones no han cambiado de un
período a otro pero este año no tengo
inversiones en bienes de capital estoy
usando el mismo camión que el año pasado
así que ahora nuestro efectivo final si
nuestro efectivo inicial fue 50 tenemos
50 de operaciones ahora nuestro efectivo
final será de 100 mil dólares espero que
esto les haya ayudado a comprender por
qué es que agregamos la depreciación
para calcular el efectivo de las
operaciones y cómo funciona nuestro
estado de cuenta de flujo de efectivo